[Music]
breakdown why you are here today
essentially what we're doing is we're
making a revenger zan Avengers type
movie trailer for the BB comic
competition like it's a pretend I'm a
superhero never done or seen before that
I know of in Big Brother history we're
gonna like pull it off off the cardboard
and we're gonna pop it up in real life
and I'm just hoping that I get to do two
chopped a couple people
I'm here to reprise the role of the
Flamingo I get to dress up like a
barbarian I'm in I think I might be the
bad guy I don't know about to kick some
butt take some names if something give
some life I'm super excited what's your
costume today oh that's a surprise gift
wait and see
only et was on set as Big Brother alums
reunited for the top-secret BB comic
shoot of course we also had to get their
take on it BB 19 hey ka big Paul are you
Team polar are you not team Paul having
not seen anything I'll say I'm team Paul
why not they are being followers and
they're playing for second everyone is
prepared to him the game to Paul I think
I would most people say what game you
know it's a one one-man show right now
and he's playing a great game it's just
not that fun to watch it's Paul is Big
Brother right now he's the puppet master
of the whole show so as his friend and
his his buddy
I totally support it you know and I want
him to win as a viewer of the show and
as trying to have an unbiased view
somebody has to rattle some feathers in
there to like liven things up maybe some
backstabbing you know what I mean these
Froot Loops are just stupid they're not
plant they're scared you know get Paul
obviously I would have struck a double
eviction what are they thinking but I'm
on the block or something you know you
know maybe see him run a little bit or
you know sweat
why and my hands are squeaky clean this
guy's got to go he's a dork I get him
out like this orchestrating everything
and I'm just like like oh I just don't
want him to any of had this safety in
the beginning and it's just like all
these things are getting handed to him
people give him crap all the time
because a production did this for him or
he's the only vet in everybody but he's
playing the cards that he's dealt and
he's doing it really well do you think
anybody can beat him this year that's
not looking like it no one's putting up
a fight at all I mean clear path there
you go if Paul's in the final two more
than likely no one's beat him if he
makes it all the way to the end and the
houseguests let him he deserves the win
if I was playing against Paul and I did
take him to the final two I don't think
my cast members would think you know he
had this entire season he worked all of
us or he beat all of us I think they
might just say he had his chance you
know at the end of it to you and still
vote for somebody of their own season
your dream final two
[Music]
you